Manchmal ist es wirklich ein wenig erschreckend auf welche ideen
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen kommen dieses mal lässt doktor frankenstein größen eine forschungsgruppe hat mäusen menschliche nervenzellen
also
Den zellen eingebaut und mal geguckt was so passiert und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes sie haben nämlich ein
Sichtfenster in den schädel gebaut um das wachstum zu beobachten und was sie dabei sehen konnten finde ich beunruhigend jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die hirnforschung macht immer größere fortschritte aber manchmal
Denke, ich um welchen preis ein forschungsteam, des soc institute for biological studies
Im kalifornischen la jolla in den usa hat jetzt mäusen hirn organe eingepflanzt und dann durch ein loch
im schädel mit einem sichtfenster
Beobachtet was mit den fällen geschieht die forschungsfrage war können solche zellen auch außerhalb der petrischale wachsen und was machen sie dann sofort
Ließen sie die zellkulturen, im labor 50 tage lang wachsen und setzen sie dann den mäusen ein damit sie die zellen dann
Im mäuse gehirn beobachten konnten
manipulierten sie die gene der zellen so dass sie grün leuchteten und das
verblüffende die zellen wuchsen und nicht nur das nach nur zwei wochen hatten sich die zellen mit dem blutkreislauf der wirtstiere
verbunden und wurden dadurch mit sauerstoff und nährstoffen versorgt und innerhalb von drei monaten wuchsen die zellen dann weiter und
Verbreiteten sich im mäuse hören sie wuchsen tief ins gehirn hinein und jetzt wird es ein bisschen spooky die beiden strukturen
verbanden sich die menschlichen und tierischen hirnzellen takten sich aufeinander ein und bildeten laut der forschungsgruppe ein
gemeinsames neuronales netzwerk hatten die forscherinnen und forscher jetzt super intelligente mäuse geschaffen
eine wirklich erschreckende vorstellung ein schreckensszenario
Super mäuse brechen aus dem labor aus und übernehmen die weltherrschaft
Naja das forschungsteam untersuchte die lösung kam zu einem eher beruhigenden ergebnis
Keine veränderung weder das verhalten der mäuse noch ihr lernvermögen ließen auf eine gesteigerte
intelligenz schließen allerdings
Schloss der forschungsleiter nicht aus dass es veränderungen gegeben haben könnte die sie aber noch nicht
festgestellt hätten allerdings nehmen sie diese ergebnisse jetzt zum anlass mit ihren forschungen fortzufahren mit diesem
Versuchsaufbau also menschlichen nervenzellen, im tierkörper wollen sie in zukunft
schizophrenie alzheimer
autismus parkinson und weiteren krankheiten erforschen sie schließen aufgrund ihrer annahmen und der ergebnisse dieser
forschungsarbeiten aus dass menschliche fähigkeiten auf die tiere
Übergehen können wenn er als erstes neues zum thema medizinische experimente aller
frankenstein und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir täglich vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
Direkt über mich in der redaktion vom krieg so mitmachen mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert und so begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines goodie
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
unvorstellbar kopf soll auf 9 körper transplantiert werden das ist auch aller doktor frankenstein ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran